♪♪♪
- We're skipping ahead, Adam.
I'm just going for 65, one and done.
- Did he just say he was
going straight to 65?
Because I think he's crazy.
Timeout, timeout, timeout, timeout, ahhh!
- Serious, bro?
[Lefkoe laughing]
- Trying to ice me, and it's
like 105 degrees out here.
♪♪♪
- Yo, Lefkoe here, kicking
it on another episode
of "Underrated," and today
we have Justin Tucker.
Not to sound like a heel,
but I think my leg puns are kinda hip.
Here's the kicker-that
was a good one, too.
State Farm with their
surprisingly great rates,
they're our sponsor.
But let's get to it, Justin Tucker,
because I don't know how
someone that everyone says
is one of the best kickers
of all time isn't a 99.
It's time to get my Madden
Ratings Adjuster on the line.
Call 'em up, Jake.
Let's do this.
- [Jake:] Calling Madden Ratings Adjuster.
- Clint, let's get right to it.
Justin Tucker, how is he not a 99?
Speak out of your face.
- He's pretty good, but we
reserve that elite, you know,
very rare 99 exclusive rating
for amazing achievements.
- All right, time to talk
to the star, Justin Tucker.
Love this dude.
Jake, call JT.
- [Jake:] Calling Justin Tucker.
♪♪♪
- Justin, man, this is a good-lookin' fit.
Olive shirt, black legs.
This is good, man.
- Normally, I'd go with,
like, the full Johnny Cash,
the black on black, but it's
like 100 degrees here today.
- All right, man.
Justin, this is Clint Oldenburg.
He is my good friend, though, at Madden.
He's gonna hook us up.
- How you doin', man?
- Hey, I'm good.
- So let's dive right into it.
Everyone knows that for your position,
the two moneymaker ratings are
kick power and kick accuracy.
And everyone also knows
that Madden has absolutely
disrespected you in these categories,
and I can't let this go unanswered,
and I know you can't either.
- [Justin:] Yeah, man.
You know, I know I'm a 98
kick power and kick accuracy.
That's what I feel like is
completely disrespectful,
and we've gotta do something about that.
- [Lefkoe:] Clint, what
yardage does he need to kick
for you to give him a 99 kick power?
- [Clint:] I think if we could see him
nail one from 65 or deeper,
then he might have a case.
- You know, that's why we're here.
We're here to address exactly that.
- Clint, this one's a
little bit interesting.
What about throw on the run?
- [Clint:] For us, I mean,
I'd love to see both
accuracy and some starch
on the throw while running
at a pretty high speed.
- I just need to warm up.
We need to get started.
We need to do this, like, right now.
- All right, I can't wait for this one.
- Clint, footage coming soon.
Thank you.
- All right.
- Justin, I remember the
first fake field-goal attempt
in Super Bowl history,
and your name was written
all over it, my man.
And if Harbaugh had listened
to me, forget the legs,
I'm using that arm
cannon of yours instead,
and that Super Bowl highlight
would look a lot different.
So here is how we're going to improve
your throw on the run rating, Mr. Tucker.
We're gonna get you that fairytale ending.
You're gonna fake the run,
you're gonna roll out to pass,
and do you see that target in the back
with the three zones in it?
The big money, that's that middle zone.
You hit that, five points.
Next best is that top one.
You hit that upper zone,
you get three, and the
bottom one gets you two.
Now, if you just hit
any part of that target,
your rating stays the same.
You miss it all together,
though, I hate to tell you,
it's going down. Cuz we're
only gonna do one actual snap
that we're using for the ratings.
Does this all make sense?
♪♪♪
- Yeah, I'm ready for live action.
- [Lefkoe:] Justin Tucker
at the line of scrimmage.
He's setting some guys in motion.
- Tune, XM60, outlaw. Call
Papa Bear, fire up the grill!
- [Lefkoe:] He's saying interesting words,
and oh, he's moving a wide receiver.
Here we go.
Everything on the line,
Justin Tucker in shotgun.
Takes the snap, fakes the handoff.
Rolls right, a lotta speed.
Corks, fires, throws.
Ah, and he hits it!
Oh, so close!
Inches away from five points.
- You know what?
I put it all out there, and I'm still,
I'm still confident,
still optimistic.
- Listen, man, I'm gonna get you on a call
with an adjuster later
so you can tell him personally how
you have felt disrespected by Madden.
- I feel like it's only
the right thing to do.
Appreciate the opportunity.
- All right, man.
I'm thinking we focus in
on kick power, shall we?
- It's time for the real deal.
Pressure's on.
♪♪♪
- [Lefkoe:] So here's
how we're gonna do this.
We're gonna start you off at 61,
and then we're gonna
move you back one yard
each time you hit the field goal.
For every one over 65,
we're gonna up your kick power rating.
Are we feeling confident about this?
- We're always feeling confident.
But hey, man, let's just do this.
- Man, let 'er rip!
♪♪♪
- [Lefkoe:] Ooh, surprisingly
great from Tucker.
- Ah, cut that one a little thin.
Still good.
- Nice, headed to 62.
Absolutely destroys it.
- I'm just gonna kick this one better.
♪♪♪
- Timeout, timeout, timeout, timeout!
Ahhh!
- Serious, bro?
Trying to ice me,
and it's like 105 degrees out here.
- Listen, these are real
in-game simulations, bro.
It is hot.
I am bringing out the ice.
- All right, well,
we'll just reset,
and we'll just knock this down then.
♪♪♪
- [Lefkoe:] This guy is a machine!
- Good!
- And it's good, at 63!
Man!
- We're skipping ahead, Adam.
I'm just going for 65, one and done.
- Did he just say he was
going straight to 65?
Because I think he's crazy.
Holy crap!
Bro, you just nailed a 65-yarder
without even breaking a sweat.
- Think we should probably keep going.
- Where are we headed next?
- I'm just gonna go bombs away from 67.
Yeah, we'll see what happens,
and we'll go from there.
- Man, he's going for 67.
Can you imagine?
- All right, here we go.
♪♪♪
Ah, crossbar!
- Crossbar, oh, man!
You were right on it, man.
- All right, fuck it.
We're done.
No, I said I was gonna make it.
I said I was gonna make it.
Fuck that.
- I am loving this fire right now.
♪♪♪
- There it is.
- Hey!
Justin Tucker from 67!
How are you feeling?
- Man, I'm just pissed
off it took me so long!
- It was sweet to watch.
How does it feel to be a living legend
that should be honored for all time?
- Ah, you know, I'm just a
guy who kicks a ball, man.
- Justin, I've got your
back, brother, always.
Clint, 65 yards and he's
throwing piss missiles.
Are you impressed?
- Hey, I am impressed.
It was, it looked like he was
breaking a sweat out there.
He was working.
That was cool.
- Well, I'm glad that you find that cool,
cuz he found it hot, and I
am not letting you reveal
your grades without him being present.
I'm getting Mr. Justin Tucker on the line.
Let's see how Clint handles the pressure.
There he is.
Look at him, see?
He's ready to work out again today, Clint.
- Hey, Justin, how you doing?
- I hear that Adam has put together
quite a compelling case for me.
So I'd love to hear what you have to say.
- Clint, it's on you now.
Field goals.
Give me the numbers.
- All right.
Let's start with the most important one.
Kick power.
Justin is going up to a 99 kick power
because he nailed those kicks on the film.
And that was great.
- I love it.
I love it.
- I'll take 99 kick
power all day, every day.
Clint, throw on the run.
We set up the targets.
What's happening with his rating?
- Going in, we had said
it would have to go in the target. However
he actually throws a really nice ball.
But he's gonna go up plus three to 23.
And that puts him as the fifth-best kicker
in the throw on the run category.
- I can respect it.
I'll take what I can get.
So, hey, a three-point
boost is better than two.
It's better than one.
It's better than negative-three.
So, I'll take it.
- OK, Clint, is Justin Tucker underrated?
- Justin Tucker is absolutely underrated.
- That's huge.
I hope that that three-point boost in the
throw on the run traits will contribute
to my overall ratings increase,
which I'm eagerly anticipating, Clint.
- Consider your case under review.
- All right.
- Clint, you are the man.
Tucker, you are the man.
Congratulations on that 99 kick power.
I love it.
And I love you guys for watching.
Thank you.
Go play Madden, with Justin Tucker's
surprisingly great new kick power rating,
and show some love to
my people at State Farm
for their surprisingly great rates.
Send them a postcard.
Companies love that shit.
I'm telling you.
♪♪♪